Let's talk next to.
Let's go to.
Why don't we go to Darren from the United
Kingdom, Darren, you're on the air.
David, how are you? I'm doing well, thank
you or thanks for the call back. My second
attempt. So so I wanted to ask you about
the fight of the evangelical church in the
in the US, because I'm a Christian. I'm from
the fact that the Episcopalian background,
Church of England and I'm seeing quite a lot of
false prophets, charlatans and ne'er do wells
in the church in England. Really? Yeah.
So what's your opinion about the idea of
the evangelical Episcopalian Church in the US?
I don't know much about the Episcopalian
Episcopalian Evangelical Church
in the US, to be quite frank. I am
I know that they are quite different than, for
example, the Catholic Church. But for me, it's
I wouldn't even be able to tell you the defining
characteristics of American Episcopalianism versus
being a Methodist or a Baptist. I, I it's sort of
beyond me. What I know is that across all sects,
we do seem to be seeing a resurgence in
the sort of prophets and future tellers,
some of the apocalyptic stuff. They've basically
all been completely wrong about everything. They
they predicted about the twenty twenty
election for sure. I mean, in in England,
what are the defining characteristics of
the of the English Episcopalian Church?
Well, we've we've gone through a transition, so
we we are quite inclusive now. So we're we're
we're breaking down barriers with with LGBT Q
Plus and undefined minorities, but want to be
open and fair. But, but, but there's been a bit
of resurgence with and we've had some some false
prophets of gaslighting and blasphemers. And even
in my church it was nearly a corrupted completely
by these people with their own hidden agenda.
And in your church, Darren, what is an example
of the prophecy that was being spewed?
I had a dream last night and God told
me blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So but what would be an example?
Like what types of prophecy are
they trying to put out there?
It is just to manipulate people to their
own ends at a grooming really. It's a
form of brooming spiritual abuse. If that's
what it is. I just I'm maybe there isn't.
Is there a specific example of a particular
prophecy that was sort of told to you? Yes,
I mean, because I suffer from mental health,
illness all of my life, I got a bit of a stammer,
as you can tell, and I was told that the
answer to these were punishments from God
because of my sin and my lack of righteousness.
And there is clearly no biblical teaching that
that is not gospel teaching at all. That that's
a perversion, a blasphemy of the teaching of
Christ to manipulate me, to put me down.
Now, Daryn, when you were told that,
did that help you in any way?
Well, I mean, I was filled with
a righteous, righteous indignation to to
to to flip back to to repel, to be and
and I stayed in that church for six years
surrounded by people who didn't like me at
all in there. And I saw them out in the end. Wow.
So but what in other words, being told that the
explanation for your issues was that you had
sinned and it was punishment from God that
didn't help you deal with the issues, when
obviously it was a life from the strike.
But it was it was a complete life, Neal, if
I could see that. Right. So so perhaps I was
blessed in that respect that you were able to know
right away you were being fed. Nonsense. Yes. Yes.
But I can see other people in England and in
us who are being played and they don't know it.
Oh, yeah, wow.
Well, Daryn,
I'm sorry to hear that. I really appreciate
you calling in and sharing your story, though.
Thanks for the call back. Great show.
All right. Thanks. There it is, Daryn,
from the United Kingdom. Wow. Things are
getting very, very real. Very real there